[Musique]
cette semaine je me trouve au centre
national du cinéma et de l'image animée
implanté dans l'ancienne batterie de
bois d'arcy bâtiments militaires du 19e
siècle ici elle est filmé des lumières
la bande de renault ou encore les films
d'agnès varda un million cent mille
boîtes 140 mille oeuvres sont conservés
au cnc et on va aller voir béatrice de
passe trè directrice des collections
pour nous expliquer justement leur
conservation
le principe de la conservation des films
c'est de garantir une température
constante et une immigrée mettrie
également constante donc on va
surveiller
j'aurais mis 365 jours sur 365 jours
et bien la température à l'intérieur des
magasins et en même temps le taux
d'hygrométrie kylie a également dans les
différentes les différentes pièces
aération des espaces aération du film à
l'intérieur de la de la boîte est comme
ça les films peuvent avoir une vie qu'on
estime aujourd'hui
sur les supports modernes en polyester
d'à peu près 300 ans pour la pellicule
noir et blanc ce qui n'est pas de
gradins disques durs numérique
on va aller au laboratoire pour voir un
petit peu les traitements que l'ontt nos
pairs sur les films pour les sauver les
restaurants
[Musique]
on
prend en charge la restauration des
films des films anciens alors très
anciens on a restauré des négatifs
lumière
c'est pour l'exposition universelle de
1900 ou des films des années 20 où des
années 60
qu'est-ce qu'on peut rappeler les
différentes étapes brièvement justement
de restauration alors en numérique il ya
de l'envié d'abord scanner le scanner le
film c'est à dire transformer l'image
argentique en fichiers numériques à
chaque photographe être affichée la
bobine a été nettoyée avant d'être
d'être scannées l escalier et puis va y
avoir le process de restauration puis le
process d'étalonnage je vous propose à
présent d'aller découvrir un trésor
conserver ici est l'écran d'épinglés un
objet d'art créée par alexandre alexiev
éclaire parker suivez moi
[Musique]
il ya cinq cent mille épingles qui sont
relativement à ces grosses en fait
donc il est assez lourd il faut plus de
150 kilos c'est pas les épingles en soi
qui font qu'ils font l'image c'est
l'ombre portée de chaque épingle sur la
surface blanche qui par une
multiplication à de plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'épinglettes créer cette
image et les contrastes qui vont avec
qui on a toutes les nuances de gris
possibles et imaginables
on peut faire des très très beau
dégrader avec cette technique et on s'en
lasse pas et après on prend des on prend
des photos et donc
voilà on prend une photo à chaque fois
ou deux plus tôt puisque en général si
on tourne à 24 images seconde
[Musique]
oh